passion is not something you were born
with drives me nuts everybody thinks
they're gonna turn inside like an
archaeologist and find that thing their
deepest passion the thing they always
love hiding inside as as soon as you say
it I hope it sounds ridiculous is no
matter what's going on you can choose to
think differently believe differently
see differently all of those things are
a choice and if you ignore everything
else this is the one where you stop and
you pay attention because this could
save years of your life you need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
nation
[Music]
he's Tom bill you and here's my take on
his top fifty rules for success volume
two
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one put in the work
alright listen and listen well because
no truer words are ever gonna be spoken
you can do anything you want without
limitation whatever it is that you
decide you want to make come true in
your life you can do that it is gonna
take an inhuman amount of work you're
gonna have to be prepared to break
yourself in half you are going to have
to learn more than anyone has ever
learned you can have to push yourself
harder than anyone has ever asked you to
push yourself before you're gonna go way
beyond your breaking point you're gonna
run until you vomit you're gonna study
until you fall asleep you're going to
push and push and push and then you're
gonna push some anymore and when you hit
the limit you're gonna push again beyond
that you're gonna force yourself into an
adaptation response and why because it's
Malcolm X said the future belongs to
those who prepare for it today so if you
don't put the work in today if you don't
do the unending back-breaking work of
developing yourself into something
greater the world is gonna pass you by
the people that are going to own it are
going to be the ones that did
the one promise that I can make you
right now is that somebody somebody out
there is out working somebody right now
is doing the things that I'm saying
somebody right now is doing the work of
failing and getting up and getting
better and pushing themselves and
triggering that glorious adaptation
response that makes humans the apex
predator someone right now they're
putting in that work and if you don't
the future is going to belong to them
and as Martin Luther King jr. said if
you can't fly
than one if you can't run then walk if
you can't walk then crawl but whatever
you do you have to keep moving forward
it's not okay to make excuses it's not
gonna slow people down it's not okay to
ask for will to stop so that you can
step out front it's not okay to expect
little of yourself and demand great
rewards the only thing that's okay is to
be in line with the way that the world
really works and if you want to be brave
you've got to become capable of
greatness
you've got to develop your skill set
you've got to take what you have now and
if that's crawling and crawl but you
drag yourself ever forward to a vision
of yourself that is so clear and so
specific that nothing
my friends know exactly where you're
going you're willing to pay whatever
price it takes to get there and no
matter what anybody says no matter how
many hecklers come for you no matter how
many people try to feel dirt on you try
to stop you try to knock you down no
matter how many people come for you
tonight while you sleep
and you will keep pushing forward and
you will get better and
and no matter how many times people
shopping you knocking
knock you off the path we will get back
on you'll crawl soon you can walk you
walk too you run
is the only path forward so if you want
the future that makes you happy
if you want a wall that you're excited
about get your ass out there and earn it
rule number two don't be passive
recently you talked about ditching
patience but I think patience helps in
the long run why do you think ditching
patience will help this is so
fascinating so patience in the long run
is the only thing that I can tell you is
guaranteed to fail there may be some
advantage to what people are the reason
that people are telling you to have
patience in the short term because
here's what anybody trying to anybody
telling you to have patience is trying
to get you to understand one very simple
thing whatever you're trying to
accomplish it takes a very long time and
so if you go into it and you're playing
this short-term game game chances are
you're gonna do things that are damaging
to your reputation long term that to me
is not patience that to me is playing
the long game you want to play the long
game you want to be authentic you want
to be a good person you want to do good
things from people you want to invest in
other people not because you're being
patient because patient to me is a very
passive position it's saying look I'm
not gonna like go all out today because
at the end of the day this is gonna take
time this is a marathon it's not a
sprint and so I need to pace myself
that's what people hear when you tell
them to be patient I know because I've
seen it play out thousands of times so
what happens when you tell people be
patient is you're telling them hey look
this is gonna take a really long time
anyway so pace yourself here's the
reality and you're you're gonna feel the
truth of this instantly most dreams
never come true most of the people that
you know most of the dreams that you've
had for yourself they haven't come true
why not because they're brutally
difficult the world is going to resist
you it is not going to be easy to
overcome entropy to overcome inertia the
only way that you're going to overcome
that stuff
to go all-out everyday knowing that it's
gonna take a long time but the only way
that that dream is gonna come true even
over that long period of time is if
you're going all-out every day so
literally a mantra in my life and I
can't I cannot stress this enough this
is a cornerstone of why I've been able
to achieve at the level that I've been
able to achieve every day everything I'm
doing I'm asking why can't it be done
faster why can't I accomplish more right
now that it's not okay to put something
off even till tonight I need to do it
right now now you need to get very good
at prioritizing because if you try and
do everything right now you're going to
accomplish nothing and if you're trying
to be gimmicky or do shortcuts all of
that's gonna fail because none of that
is playing the long game but if ever
you're allowing yourself to slow down
because you simply are acknowledging
that this stuff takes time I'm telling
you it's never going to work you've got
to go all-out you've got to create
momentum rule number three have maniacal
focus this is critical whatever it is
that you're going to do in your life if
you have any interest in doing something
extraordinary if you have any interest
in performing better than other people
if you have any interest in doing
something that will be remembered this
is the takeaway for you pick one thing
and do it with force and determination
the only way that you're going to be
able to push past the mountain of
obstacles that is going to try to stop
you is to have maniacal focus to know
exactly what you want to have clarity of
purpose to have a crystal clear vision
in your mind of what you're trying to
accomplish something that you could tell
anybody in a single sentence when you
have that and you stare at it all day
and you think about exactly how you're
gonna make it happen and you tie your
identity to it then you've got a chance
because then my
when that obstacle comes before you you
will muster the force that you need to
destroy that obstacle and this is where
this kind of aggressive language and
thinking is going to help you because
they will not go quietly and that's the
problem that a lot of good gentle
beautiful Souls have is when the time
comes they don't muster the force that's
required to get what they want
and I know you know like I do somebody
who's a beautiful person who's a good
human being that we wish good things for
but sometimes bad things happen because
they don't stand up for themselves and
as jaco willing said most of us aren't
defeated in one decisive battle we're
defeated one tiny seemingly
insignificant surrender at a time that
ships away at who we should really be
that's how we lose rule number four
optimize your life how important is rest
and how much do you get of it I'm trying
hard at the moment to pursue my dreams
but sometimes I feel out of balance
because I lack sleep for example all
right boys and girls I'm telling I'm
just gonna be super arrogant for a
second I built a billion-dollar business
without setting an alarm prioritize
sleep I work a lot in fact I'll take the
Pepsi challenge anybody that wants to go
head to toe with me in terms of what you
get done not just raw number of hours
aimed at a computer or whatever it is
that you're supposed to be doing and
performing totally sub-optimally I'll
just take the Pepsi challenge on that I
always prioritize sleep I always
prioritize my psychological optimization
so for instance if I'm working around
the clock if this happened not too long
ago I was just working so many hours and
it ended up encompassing too many things
that took more energy than they were
giving that I started to feel anxious
isn't in fact I started to feel
claustrophobic that's exactly how I felt
I wanted to crawl out of my own skin I
don't know how to explain it it's just
like ah just driving me nuts and I
realized I need to chill for a minute I
need to meditate I need to take an hour
and go do something that's still moving
me tour
my dreams because that's my thing but
that I really enjoy and so maybe in
those moments I go read a comic because
we're building a comic book publishing
Empire so that's part of what I need to
do anyway but reading the comic is fun I
also need to meditate and just literally
breathe from my diaphragm so get the
sleep do you need that's super critical
you do not need to set an alarm sleep as
much as you need to and by the way if
you're doing things that are exciting to
you you're I know people some of you are
gonna believe me because I hopefully
I've earned the credibility with you up
to this point and some of your gonna
call total bullsh you can ask my wife I
can set an internal alarm clock in my
mind only if I'm excited about something
or really stressed out but that's all
another thing which I try hardly to do
ever but when I'm really excited about
something I can set an internal alarm
clock this morning I told myself wake up
at 4:15 what time did I wake up boys and
girls not for 14 not for 16 I woke up at
4:15 because that was the time that I
told myself to wake up I can usually get
within 5 minutes of what time I tell
myself to wake up it doesn't always work
and if I'm tired I don't give myself
that edict I tell myself to sleep as
much as I need but when I'm really
excited about something there's
something I want to get up and work on
and I'm afraid there just won't be
enough time and it's a reasonable amount
of sleep I'll say anything north of 5
hours I can usually get myself to just
wake up so get the sleep prioritize
cognitive optimization because then
you're efficient and efficiency is the
name of the game so sleep sleep sleep I
am NOT a guy proposing the you know set
your alarm get up at 4 a.m. no matter
what it's not me go to bed early get
your sleep meditate getting a good
peaceful calm creative state so that you
can really crush it also if you want to
learn how to have more confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below there's a gap between
who people are and what they tell you
they want to accomplish rule number 5
explore life would you be in favor of
college students or anyone that may be
considering it to take some time off to
travel and experience as many new things
as they can in order to find themselves
so absolutely but not to find themselves
so you
create yourself you decide who you want
to become but figuring out who it is
that you want to become that is
something that requires you to encounter
a lot of things to experience a lot of
life this is Kevin Kelly's whole notion
of don't prematurely optimize I think
that some of the best advice young
people are ever going to hear is you
really want to go out and explore
discover new things so that you can find
what it is that you find interesting
then that's where the discovery process
ends in the developing process begins
then you begin to create this notion of
who you want to become and then you go
down the path of becoming that gaining
those skills developing mastery in a
certain area but first really make sure
because you're gonna give at least a
decade of your life if not more to any
one thing so making sure that that's
something that fills you up instead of
chipping away at you is really really
important and the only way to do that is
to experience a whole lot of stuff so
yeah I have no beef with taking that
time off to go explore and discover new
things I think it's incredibly powerful
rule number six be yourself you've got
two choices in life choice one you can
become somebody else choice - you can
become yourself now I really wish that
there was only one choice but in truth
there's not and most people choose to
try to become someone else because it's
a road map its points in a direction you
see someone you respond to something you
admire them you want to be like them and
in that process
you've made your decision in that
process you decided to become somebody
else you have mistaken the finger for
the moon instead you need to understand
them being inspired by somebody does not
mean to become that person to become
that which inspires you it is to
understand fundamentally what is it
about that thing that excites you what
is it what is its essence
and when you can find its essence then
you can find out how it would apply to
you becoming you and as then she says
flower does not think about competing
with the flower next to it it just
blooms and that's really your job is to
see the outside world to see the flower
next to you to understand the amazing
things that are happening all around you
all of the incredible people and the
essence of what they have and what it is
that they've done to bring inside
yourself and find out what does that
look like when it's me not what do I
look like when I'm them and once you
understand the difference between that
then you can really begin to be
something unique you can become that
thing that you were meant to be that
thing that makes you feel alive and
whole and that's it that's the secret
you're just trying to be something not
that's just inspiring to other people if
you actually want to wake up every day
and be thing about it
some escaping you whatever you become a
lie the truth somebody else yourself
whatever it is
anyway
of your life there and as Albert
Einstein said everybody is a genius but
if you judge a fish by its ability to
climb a tree it will live it's whole
life believing that it's stupid that's
what confuses people people believe that
they're done because they're not finding
their path they're not defining things
based on what excites them and what they
want to live
they're just looking to what the outside
world says is good and I think it's
incredible if there are other people
doing things that are so extraordinary
that we aspire to be like that you have
to understand the difference between
being like someone and trying to
actually be
rule number seven have self-esteem we
talk of self-esteem in one of two ways
either as the sole determinant of
success or as the ultimate enemy most
people build their self-esteem around
their accomplishments they feel good
about themselves if they're making the
most money they're dating the hottest
person or they've built the best product
they get caught in the rat race of
validating themselves against the person
who happens to be standing next to them
but there's a fundamental flaw with this
equation because when your ego is that
attached to your success its devastated
by your failures and what the most
successful people know is you cannot
leave your self-worth in the hands of
anyone else the most successful people
get their pride from a different source
one that does not fluctuate with their
successes and failures so I knew I
couldn't give up my self-esteem I
couldn't accept some weird role where I
just was always the dumbass sitting in
the corner if I pride myself on being
smart and you tell me I'm dumb and you
put up a pretty good case for it that's
gonna damage my self-esteem my
self-esteem in that situation is very
fragile
if on the other hand you tell me that
I'm dumb and I build my self-esteem
around being the learner now I'm gonna
say thank you please tell me in what way
that I'm dumb because you will open my
eyes to something that now I can address
and I can go learn about that thing and
I will have a new skill and I can go out
and push and execute against that skill
one of the most powerful things that you
could do is become the person that
admits that you're wrong really fast and
it's crazy how much credibility you will
earn with people simply by admitting I
was wrong like 30 seconds ago I was
fighting so hard for something I was
really fighting for my position and then
somebody says something and I realized
that's actually better imagine it the
more you try to tell me I'm dumb the
more areas that you point out that I'm
weak the more things you tell me I need
to learn about my eyes are open to
something that if true I'm gonna go down
that path and I'm gonna learn how to
that and that is absolutely critical
rule number eight build your reality
what are your thoughts on changing
reality with thoughts and repetitions
will this workers adjust the theory okay
so there's no doubt that the way that
the brain rewires itself is through
repetition neurons that fire together
wire together so you very much can
create reality I want to say that it
isn't unfortunately like the matrix but
it's so close that you might as well
think of it like that but to me that's
just a metaphor to get people to
understand that you really can influence
your your hardwiring in your own brain
and you certainly can influence the
outside world by gaining a set of skills
that allow you to go out and manipulate
it and I'll give you a super easy
example learning to build a house means
you can actually build a house and you
can manifest that and turn a tree or
concrete into a physical structure so
you can definitely have that kind of
influence you can obviously influence
other people by learning about
psychology so all of these things are
very very possible rule number nine
change your beliefs the matrix has you
now the matrix to me is a simple
metaphor I don't actually believe that
we're living in the computer simulation
and even if we are I don't think that it
matters but what does matter is your
entire life is being lived by your brain
now what do I mean by that if you know a
guy named David Eagleman he wrote a book
called incognito in the book incognito
he makes one thing abundantly clear you
live in a virtual environment whether
you realize it or not that virtual
environment is created by the three
pounds of squishy material between your
ears
think about this your brain never
touches light your brain is encased in a
bone box in total darkness and yet it
takes photons that fall on the eye and
turns it into electrochemical stimulus
and from that it paints this environment
it fakes the sense of depth think about
this for a second there's not some
little image of this room projected into
the back of my mind this is all being
turned into electrochemical stimulus and
my brain then manufactures this
environment there's actually a dime
a blank part in your field of vision
where each optic nerve connects to your
eyes and yet you have no experience of
it that is completely invisible to you
even though its massive and it's dead
center in your eyes the reason that you
don't experience it is because your
brain fills it in your brain makes a
guess as to what would be there and your
brain is so good at guessing and so good
at presenting it as if it were real that
you have no sense it is completely
seamless to you when I heard that I
remember getting the chills and setting
the book down and saying my brain is
lying to me that rat now the question
becomes if this is all made up if the
sense of distance between you and I is
completely manufactured by my brain and
it's not real meaning what I see of it
it's real enough and that if I walk I'll
hit you at about the point that I'm
expecting to bump into you because my
brain can create that sense of distance
but it's doing it by translating those
signals it's manufacturing this space so
if that's true and my brain fills in the
gaps does my brain also have biases and
the answer is yes
neuroscience has gone deep into how many
different biases that we have as humans
I'll give you one because this one is
profoundly impactful you're more likely
to believe something negative than you
are something positive now think about
how that can echo through your life each
of us has to realize that all of the
beliefs that we have in our life are
choices the scary part about the most
important beliefs in your life as most
of them are invisible I'm going to give
you a couple questions that will
highlight invisible beliefs that you
have that are controlling your life that
are exactly why I say the matrix has you
because depending on how you answer
these questions will determine your life
and if you don't recognize something
scary in your own answers think about
the people that you love that you want
to help and you can't and you wonder why
the answer is almost certainly related
to how they answer some of these
questions number one this comes from
Einstein he said the most important
decision
the most important decision any human
being must make is whether or not you
live in a friendly or a hostile universe
now we could have said realization but
he didn't he said decision you have to
decide because there is no empirical
truth you don't live in either a
friendly or a hostile universe you
decide and that perception that
viewpoint from which you judge
everything else that happens in your
life will be colored by whether or not
you think it is a universe that is
working for you or against you and it's
a choice but most people think of their
viewpoint is being patently real as
being just objective and true and so
they never stop to question the fact
that they actually decided that at some
point either because their parents acted
in accordance with that it was either
hostile or friendly and they just
absorbed that or their friends or the
people that they work with or whatever
but somewhere along the line they came
to believe that they live in either a
friendly or a hostile universe but you
could change right now right now you
could make a different decision and if
you believe that the world is working
against you right now you could choose
to believe that it's actually working
for you and in making a fundamentally
new and different assumption it empowers
you to move forward and this is
something that I will repeat in this
talk the reason that matters is human
beings do not invest energy in things
that they don't think will yield a
result rule number ten enjoy the moment
as Martin Luther said even if I knew
that tomorrow the world would go to
pieces I would still plant my apple tree
some things you build whether you can
control the outcome or not sometimes
it's the process that is the thing
that's meant to be enjoyed it's the
process that you're meant to invest in
and rather than always thinking about
the goal the outcome or what you're
going to get out of something focus on
the something focus on the part of it
that you can control because you can't
always control the outcome you can't
know what's gonna happen tomorrow
tomorrow's not guaranteed to any of us
and yet we all act and yet we create
momentum in our
we're at our best but we do that not
because we can control every aspect we
do that because we accept that there are
things that we cannot control
and as steve maraboli said incredible
change happens in your life when you
decide to take control of what you do
have power over instead of craving
control over what you don't and that's
where a lot of people get lost
they focus not on what they have in
their hands they focus instead on the
things that they can't control it
irritates them it frustrates them it's
like a splinter in their mind they can't
stop thinking about the things that they
don't have control over and they're
blinded to the incredible wealth that is
around them of things that they could
enjoy right here right now
that's why gratitude is such an
empowering practice to sit there and not
think of the glorious things may await
you in your future but rather to think
about the things that you have here in
this moment oxygen in your lungs a
simple breeze on your face a window in
your house someone that you love someone
that loves you nothing that costs money
nothing that was the pot of gold at the
end of a glorious rainbow it's not even
about becoming something extraordinary
and waiting for the results of that it's
simply understanding that the one thing
you can control are your actions today
the choices that you make what you get
to do how you think about yourself the
beliefs you choose to bring into your
life those
you control and when you understand the
power in acknowledging that control and
taking control and using it that's when
your life is going to begin to change
but first you have to divorce yourself
from being obsessively interested only
in an outcome if instead you build your
self-esteem you build your pride on
pursuit you build your pride on allowing
yourself to care about something so
deeply that even though tomorrow is not
guaranteed that you're going to plant
your apple tree today that you're going
to love that process because it is the
thing that you can control you can
control how you show up you can control
how you play you cannot control how
other people react you cannot control
what they think about you but you can
control what you think about yourself
you can earn credibility with yourself
you can control what you do and when you
take full ownership of that and realize
that your life is an exact reflection of
the GWAR choices of the things you could
control and what you did with them then
everything begins to change you're not
looking to blame somebody else you're
not even worried
anybody else you're just asking one
simple question
what can I do right now regardless of
tomorrow to improve my life today
focus there and you'll enjoy every day
of your life rule number 11
don't let obstacles break you as
Confucius said when it's obvious that
the goal cannot be reached don't adjust
the goals adjust the action steps that
may be the single best piece of advice
you're ever going to get write that down
burn it into your flesh tattoo it on
your soul do whatever you need to do to
remember that once you set a goal once
you've decided in your life there is
something that you're going to make come
true don't let anything stop you from
reaching that but the reality is is you
go things are gonna get in your way
there will be an inevitable slew of
obstacles coming at you but when it gets
so hard that you realize that the path
that you're on is simply not going to
take you where you want to go rather
than give up on what it was you said you
were gonna do find a different path and
in that when you really make that a
cornerstone of your identity that you
refuse to bend or be broken by obstacles
by challenges but instead you rise to
those challenges you go over under
through them you do whatever you have to
you devise any plan to find a way
through then your life will change once
that becomes your reaction to not change
that thing that meant so much to you
you've dedicated your life to making it
come true that you don't change that but
rather you find another way you tap into
your creativity you find somebody that
can help you you do whatever it takes to
get on the other side of that you do
whatever it takes to build that life
that you want to see but if your
reaction is to change your goal to make
it easier to move it closer to be less
of who you could be simply so you can
check a box you're never gonna have
anything that's worth having real number
12 take the first step why like if you
had to boil it down why didn't even feel
got it locked the answer is they never
start
now the reason that most people never
start is because they don't think that
they're gonna get a result from their
actions and then that's gonna come down
to a belief that they believe about
themselves I'm too stupid I'm not good
enough I don't have the natural talent
I wasn't born at the right time or in
the right neighborhood my parents didn't
teach me that that's why most people
fail there's a great quote by Amelia
Earhart I'll paraphrase the hard thing
is taking the first step everything else
is just persistence and I've always
loved that quote because it's so true it
doesn't mean that you're going to get it
right it doesn't mean that just because
you start you're gonna win in fact most
likely the first thing you do you're
gonna fail think about all the times
that you guys tried something and it
failed or the first time when you tried
to get the business going and it didn't
work or the first house you tried to
sell nobody went for it or the first
time that you lost money and the
question is what did you do then if you
learned from it DoubleDown figured it
out focused only on the truth then
you'll move forward you move forward
because you believe you can learn and
that's that thing hiding in that and
this is the thing when people ask me hey
my mom or my wife or my husband whatever
they don't have that belief system they
don't have what Carol Dweck calls a
growth mindset how do I get them there
the answer is you don't until they are
convinced that they can learn anything
that they put their mind to that their
energies double down into that area of
gaining skills will actually pay off
with a real-world ability to do
something new they're not going to act
rule number 13
outwork everyone Kobe Bryant one of the
greatest athletes of our time would show
up on game day and if he saw anybody
else at the gym as early as him even
though he was always the first on the
court he would end up practicing longer
than that person and I had the honor of
interviewing one of those people one
time and he said I went up in ask Kobe
Kobe we have a game in an hour like what
are you doing out here practicing so
long and Kobe said I needed you to know
that I was willing to outwork you and in
that game they ended up winning and that
lesson stuck with that
forever when you're willing to put in
the work when you're willing to take
control of your environment and put
yourself through the stressors required
for adaptation you literally can become
anything and my life is proof of that
rule number 14 prepare for the luck I
hear people talk about luck a lot and I
know that people think about the role
that luck plays in their life but the
reality is luck is all around luck is
ever-present luck literally is coming to
you every day it's passing you by it's
happening to you right now but the
question is are you able to take
advantage of the luck
have you prepared for the luck and I
think that it comes down to we have a
misconception about what luck is we
think of luck as something as being
passive that we sit and we wait we're in
some obscure place and still somehow the
luck finds us but the reality is were
awash in luck what we're missing is the
ability to make use of it if you have a
bunch of bullets but no gun you really
have nothing if you have a gun but no
bullets the same thing that magic moment
comes together when you have two things
that work in conjunction and you have
them both you can't have luck without
the diligence you can't have success
without the skills you've got to spend
your life preparing to capitalize on
that look and to look at what somebody
has done to look at a moment of success
in their life and to say that it was
luck is to create a frame of reference
for you in which you can't see how you
yourself can leverage what you have to
get lucky
rule number 15 find deep fulfillment one
thing I want to make really clear and if
you ignore everything else this is the
one where you stop and you pay attention
because this could save years of your
life the game you're playing is not
success the game you're playing is not
money the game you're playing is brain
chemistry the only thing that matters in
life truly the only thing that matters
in life is what you think about yourself
when you're by yourself and have nothing
but your own thoughts
if in that moment you feel good about
who you are who you're becoming what
you're capable of and what you're
willing to do to make a better future
for yourself those you care about and
other people around you you will love
your life it is the single most
pleasurable neurochemical state is deep
fulfillment okay not happiness a bowl of
ice cream brings me a lot of happiness
but it is a very transient experience
deep and lasting fulfillment matters and
what that comes down to is how you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself
rule number 16 know your why the piece
of advice that I always give to somebody
whether it's an entrepreneur or somebody
who wants to be the greatest parent of
all time what is your goal you've got to
start with your goal
everything works backwards from that
Simon and I did a video that essentially
broke the internet about Millennials
somebody watch that what got Simon on
the world stage is this whole concept of
why you've got to know why you're doing
what you're doing if you're just showing
up every day to cut and dye hair to keep
your lights on you're gonna have far
less energy to make it through the hard
times than somebody who is there to help
transform somebody to help make somebody
their best to help them feel their best
and I hope that you guys saw that video
not too long ago of the hairdresser that
went around and he was doing makeovers
on homeless people right men
it was incredible it was so beautiful
the look on their face at that moment
where they see themselves for the first
time in front of the mirror and they are
seeing something totally new they're
seeing a version of themselves that they
did not know was there and the ability
to give that gift like it is so easy to
get lost in the day-to-day grind of what
you do what any of us do
but if at the core I give you is a deep
and unending why for what you're doing
you've got something now you've got a
chance to transcend what you're doing
and the way that happens is very
tactical has nothing to do with like
whoo being down there it's none of that
you're gonna have the energy that you
need to fight through rule number 17
protect your vision we get to decide who
we are there's no objective truth that
you're going to find or uncover you're
simply the collection of the things that
you believe to be true about yourself
and once you begin to form that opinion
of who you are you'll act in accordance
with that belief you begin to shape a
vision of yourself in your own mind and
that becomes the reality so letting
other people influence that letting
other people come in and degrade what
you think of yourself is one of the most
dangerous and damning things that you
could do because they cloud your ability
to craft to craft a vision of the person
that you want to become and that vision
is so hard for all of us to hold on to
that we have to protect it we have to
keep other people out of that we've got
to have intention in creating the person
that we want to become rule number 18
get better you are all hopelessly
average by birth we all are and that's
the great news because the most
important thing to understand about the
human species we are the ultimate
adaptation machine if you guys were
paying attention not too long ago they
sequenced the human genome and they
realized that the human genome has
20,000 genes and everybody they thought
that they were going to cure cancer all
the diseases age-related disease
everything type one type type type two
diabetes was all
be a thing in the past we were gonna
have it figured out and then we realized
that an onion has more genetic diversity
than we do and how could that be and so
they're literally going is this really
possible do we misunderstand something
like how is it that an onion has more
genetic diversity than we have and
somebody finally said hey maybe all this
stuff that we've been referring to as
junk DNA maybe it actually plays a role
and then they began to realize that all
that junk DNA that was outside of those
20,000 genes we saw expressing
themselves is what is called epigenetics
now if you've ever heard of epigenetics
that's amazing you're way ahead if you
haven't heard of epigenetics let it
become one of the most important things
in your life because epigenetics is what
has made us the most dominant species
this planet has ever seen it is the only
thing that you need to know it's what I
call the only belief that matters the
only belief that matters is that you can
learn anything I don't need you to
believe that you're good now that
doesn't matter who you are now is
totally irrelevant the only thing I want
to know who are you willing to become
and what's the price you're willing to
pay to get there and that's what humans
are designed to do if you put us under
stress we can learn something new we can
get better rule number 19 turn negatives
into positives what are some ways that I
can stop giving this negative feedback
to myself okay so first of all you've
got to train yourself to use the
negative thoughts that you have as a
habit loop trigger of something positive
that's the first step to all of this so
I don't think anybody is going to be
able to get rid of the negative voice
and even if you could I actually don't
think you would want to I think the
reality is you want to use that as your
jujitsu flip to get over to the positive
way of thinking to get into that
positive habit loop to remind yourself
that even if you're not good at it yet
you can get good at it that you're going
to learn by whatever you're doing
rule number 20 build the life that you
want I don't think people really realize
we construct our lives we build them
from nothing we decide what our goals
we decide in what way to move we decide
who we're going to become and what we're
going to get but it's a decision it's a
process it isn't something that somebody
hands to you and so if you find that
your life is a misery understand that
your life is an exact reflection of your
choices and if you want a different life
you need to only make a different choice
but I know right now many of you are
thinking but I don't know what way to go
I don't know what choice to make I don't
know what it is that I want to do and as
Roy Maurice Keene said I don't believe
skill was or ever will be the result of
coaches it is a result of a love affair
between the child and the ball so ask
yourself what's that things you love and
don't judge yourself if it was something
that you loved as a child that people
are telling you you couldn't possibly
make money and it's that part of the
equation that I want to break for people
I want you to understand
stop asking yourself what you can make a
lot of money yet and start asking
yourself what would you enjoy what is
that life that you don't need to escape
from what is the life that is your love
what is the thing that as a kid you did
whether people wanted you to or not what
is the thing you would sneak out that
night to do because you weren't gonna be
stopped from doing it everybody has
something like that in their life some
spark of interest maybe long-dormant
maybe that they've pushed aside because
they think it's stupid
or maybe they failed once and they think
they're bad at it
even though they love it that sting of
the failure has convinced them to stop
pursuing it but at the end of the day
the only thing that matters is what it
gives you that energy an end of the date
thing that matters is what fills you
with joy at the end of the day the only
thing that matters it's not success
ensure this hell isn't money
about yourself me you're by yourself
it's the things that give you energy
it's what you think about yourself it's
how you react to the hard things whether
or not you push you and when you push
through when you persevere when you go
down the process of taking the time to
structure your life to build it into
something that you want it to be to
build it into something that you're
proud of to become the person that's
capable of the things you want to do
that can first fall in love with
something and do it for the love of it
and not worry about what other people
think if you hate your life I guarantee
you the thing is that you were trapped
by what other people think you don't
want to give it up because somebody will
think you're a failure you don't want to
give it up because it's a paycheck you
don't want to give it up because you're
scared you're scared you don't know what
you'll do next but imagine a world for a
second well all you thought about was
what do you love what do you enjoy in
that moment it doesn't matter if it
changes from day to day just what do you
love what fills you with joy what gives
you that energy at the end of the day
the only thing that we all have is right
now this moment it's what you're
experiencing loving what you do how you
spend your time that's the point of all
of it
the point of life is that in each
transient moment that passes by doing
something that fills you with joy nobody
can give you that
he's got to build that life so go out
figure out what it is that you want to
do and brick by brick have the courage
to build that life rule number 21
outwork talent as Henry Rollins said I
don't have talent so I just get up
earlier the thing that people think
about becoming great about doing the
extraordinary is that it's just meant
for some people and not meant for others
and they spend their time making other
people extraordinary as a way to let
themselves off the hook because if
somebody is just gifted if they were
blessed by God if they were touched by
an angel and then just have something
that you don't and something that you
never will have then it's fine for them
to be great and you to be ordinary but
the reality is it's not how it works
but somehow the cultural narrative has
become one where we celebrate natural
talent that if somebody is graced by God
that if they have something divine about
them that they're somehow better that
it's more beautiful than the scrappy
person who's had to work for everything
they've ever had
the guy who simply acknowledges like
Henry Rollins that he doesn't have more
talent than the next person he's simply
willing to how work them he's willing to
set the alarm to get up to do whatever
it takes to find his path to create that
skill to outwork talent to show that by
putting in that energy and that effort
there's a magnification effected as far
greater than anything that can be given
to you but stowed upon you you have to
grab it
to take it you have to have a level of
intensity in your life to be able to
leverage it and create something amazing
and as Warren Buffett said intensity is
the price of excellence if you want to
be great
you've got to cultivate that intensity
you've got to understand it's not about
what you were born with it's not about
what you've been getting where you
started or even where you're going it is
entirely about what you plant at the
center of your soul how hard you're
willing to go after something how much
focus you're willing to put in your life
and how often you come back to that
level of intensity for who you want to
be because if you want to meet excellent
you will have to pay a price and that
price is eternal vigilance vigilance
over how you spend your time vigilance
over the demands you make of yourself
vigilance over what you allow yourself
to think and believe and when you get to
the point that you only allow yourself
to think and believe things that move
you towards your goals that every day
the actions you take are things that are
designed to get you there and then you
have the intensity to follow that
through to shape yourself to create a
new version of you capable of doing
something extraordinary then your life
is gonna be what you want but not until
then it's never gonna be anything if you
just make other people extraordinary and
say I could never do that but the
reality is you could and you're just not
so the thing you have to face right now
is that it is within your grasp you just
have to go after him rule number 22 gain
the mastery and let me tell you passion
is not something you were born with
drives me nuts everybody thinks they're
gonna turn inside like an archaeologist
and find that thing their deepest
passion the thing they always love
hiding inside as soon as you say it I
hope it sounds ridiculous that you would
love something that much and yet somehow
be blind to it it doesn't work like that
it's like real love you've got to go on
a date first you see somebody you're
interested in you talk to them it sparks
something you spend time you engage and
through that process of engaging with it
maybe if you're lucky it turns into a
fascination but if you really want a
passion you've got to go through the
process of gaining mastery and mastery
is the part of the relationship and
business or in romance where everybody
falls apart because it's where the work
starts it's where you have to do things
long after it stopped being fun
rule number 23 alter your beliefs now
the process of taking myself from
scrounging my couch cushions to find
enough change to put gas in my car to
building a billion-dollar business was
all about building a set of beliefs now
I believe that the matrix has us all I
don't actually think we live in a
simulation but I think the movie The
Matrix is the perfect metaphor for the
human experience we have all pulled a
web of lies over our own eyes and the
web of lies is what you tell yourself
about what's possible for you and for
the world and once you get that web of
lies over your eyes you simply see it as
reality and you don't understand that
each one of those fundamental beliefs is
alterable that you could choose to
believe something else in fact you don't
even realize that they are beliefs I
sign as a quote it's one of the most
important quotes in my life the most
important question any man must decide
for himself is whether or not
he lives in a friendly or hostile
universe now what I love about that
quote so it's hiding in it is that it's
a decision you get to choose whether
you're living in a friendly or a hostile
universe there's no objective reality it
just is what it is you're gonna get what
you see you're gonna get what you focus
on and you see what you focus on
rule number 24 don't chase perfection so
many people are obsessed with becoming
perfect that they never take action and
they never learn to enjoy this moment
that may be one of the greatest
tragedies any of us can face that right
now whatever we are however we are
however good we are whatever we've
accomplished that we fail to enjoy this
moment because we have a judgment about
who we are deep down because we haven't
acted in a way that's perfect and I get
it we have this drive it's innate in us
we want to be great it's one of the five
primary human drivers to pursue mastery
to want to master something and truly be
extraordinary I understand the drive but
don't let it corrode you don't ever do
something that eats you alive from the
inside you've got to have a vision of
yourself that allows you to morph and
change and learn from your mistakes but
if you value perfection over learning
then you're never gonna become the
person that you'd be capable of becoming
and as Anna Quindlen said the thing that
is really hard and really amazing is
giving up on being perfect and beginning
the work of becoming yourself real
number 25 enjoy the now let me tell you
something that is true beyond measure
the struggle is guaranteed the success
is not the struggle is a guarantee so
you better love what you do on a
day-to-day basis read Eckhart Tolle is
the power of now the only moment that's
real is right now now follows you so
every time you're doing something if
you're standing
staring and waiting for someone to
finish going to the restroom or whatever
you're standing in line at Disneyland
that is your life that is the sum total
of what you are about in that moment and
life is simply a string of those moments
and so you've got to start asking
yourself am i using those moments wisely
rule number 26 focus on the beauty
everything around you is incredible if
you're willing to look at it that way
everything around you can be taken for
granted if that's your perspective but
it really is about the frame that you
choose to put around things I mean
simply being alive is already insane the
odds are so stacked against you not only
just being a human but being a human at
this moment in time this moment in time
will breakthroughs in technology are
happening at an unprecedented rate where
breakthroughs in medical science are
happening at an unprecedented rate where
our ability to connect with people to
empathize with people all the way around
the globe all of the changes that have
happened in technology and telecom and
connectivity health everything we're
living in the most miraculous time ever
but you have to look at it that way and
as Joseph Campbell said life is a
wonderful wonderful opera except that it
hurts so the question is do you see it
is the beautiful opera or do you just
pay attention to the pain and at the end
of the day you're gonna get what you
focus on they're both true this is both
the most amazing time that's ever
happened ever in recorded history and
you have real things that are terrifying
or also happening
but where you put your energy where you
put your attention where you put your
focus is going to determine what you see
and that is the most fascinating and the
most important thing you have to
understand about the way that your mind
works you get when you focus on if you
focus on the things that are bad they
would become real they will become
exaggerated they will begin to
monopolize your thoughts you'll see them
everywhere it's called the reticular
activating system your mind is literally
designed to pay attention to the things
that you notice once you notice a
certain car you see it everywhere once
you notice a certain dog you see it
everywhere once you hear a certain name
for the first time suddenly realize that
that name has been all around you this
entire time but now that you're focusing
on it now that you're looking for it it
is everywhere so whatever you look for
it's gonna be everywhere if you look for
the negative it'll be there but if you
look for the positive it will overwhelm
you rule number 27 become anti fragile
and if you guys haven't read the book
anti fragile buying the seem to leb do
in that book he lays out the difference
between something that is resilient and
something that is truly anti fragile I'm
gonna say somebody that's unstoppable is
truly anti fragile and what anti fragile
is the more you attack it the stronger
it gets there's something that is
resilient or tough it is still defined
by its breaking point the more you go
after it eventually it will break
something that Fanty fragile grows with
that and I believe each and every one of
us can build a mindset that is truly
anti fragile there's only one thing that
I have found that is actually anti
fragile and it looks like this I was
there with my partners they routinely
made me feel stupid all the time they
were older than me they were more than
10 years ahead of me on their
entrepreneurial journey and so I was
just wrong all the time now up to that
point in my life I actually called
myself the king of remedial jobs up
until then I'd only gone for jobs where
I knew I'd be smarter than the person
interviewing me I knew that at some
point during the interview there
ask that magical question which made me
feel so good about myself which was why
are you here
why are you interviewing for this job
and I lived for that because it made me
feel smart so here I am now not in that
world anymore I'm with guys were way
ahead of me they're way smarter than me
and I feel dumb all the time and one day
I find myself arguing for this path and
our business because it was my idea and
I knew it was wrong that was a hilarious
thing I knew it was wrong and yet I was
arguing for it like really passionately
and then all of a sudden it actually
worked and they agreed to do it and I
thought oh now what I've been telling my
wife that I'm gonna make her rich and
here I am arguing for something that
just makes me feel good about myself and
I had this moment of crisis and I asked
myself no judgement what do you really
want because if what you really want is
to feel good about yourself to feel
smart to be right to be worthy if those
are the things that you want then get
out of this company because you're wrong
often you're making mistakes all the
time and your partners are so far ahead
of you that they make you feel stupid so
this is like that doesn't make any sense
so if you want to just go feel good go
back to being the king of remedial jobs
be in places where you're always feeling
smart where you're usually right and
live that life but if on the other hand
what you really want is to actually
reach your goals then you're gonna have
to stop worrying about feeling good
about yourself and both of those felt
flawed everybody needs to feel good
about themselves that that's just the
reality of being a human you've got to
find a way to feel good about yourself
but I really believe everything you do
in life should be in service of your
goals and the moment that you're acting
out of alignment with your goals you
might have a problem with your goal or
with your behavior one of them is gonna
have to change and so I realized in that
moment that I needed to change what I
was building
self-esteem around because I was
building it around being right and that
was wrong so much I was building it
around being smart and I just wasn't
that smart I was building it around
being good and worthy and the fact is
those were just judgements on myself and
so I decided right then and there it's
the one thing in my life that borders on
truly being an epiphany
and I realized I need to change what I
build my self-esteem around and it needs
to be something that I didn't have the
word anti fragile at the time but
something that the more somebody goes
after it the better off I'm going to be
the more it's gonna push me towards my
goals and that thing is and if somebody
has a better answer I will take it but
the only way to build your ego that is
truly anti fragile that I have found is
to be the learner to be willing to admit
when you're wrong to look at your goal
and work backwards and say is what I'm
doing actually moving me towards my goal
or not not does it make me feel good
about myself not am i right not am i
smart is it moving me towards my goal
and if it is then you do it and if it
doesn't then you don't and my life
became that cut-and-dry and you can
literally draw a line in the sand a
demarcation point of my life before that
and my life after that rule number 28
move forward as Kurt Vonnegut one of the
greatest authors in modern times said
when I write I feel like an armless
legless man with a crayon in his mouth
but he still did it and that's the kind
of thing that you're gonna hear from the
greats you're not gonna hear that it was
easy you're not gonna hear that they
felt suave and cool even the greatest of
all time have that awkwardness not
clumsiness they're never quite as good
as they want to be but what I want you
to understand is even though Kurt
Vonnegut said those words he wrote tons
of books that changed people's lives
that changed the landscape of literature
because despite the fact that he felt
awkward and clumsy he kept doing it and
doing it and forcing himself to move for
to take one step after another even when
the process was not exactly rewarding
he believed in something he knew that
what he was trying to do would
ultimately get better he knew that if he
wanted to accomplish something great
that he had to push through the
awkwardness and that is the very trick
to getting great you just have to do it
you have to go you have to take that
first step you up to push you have to
drive you've to strive every time to get
a little bit better you have to strive
not to fall prey to your own doubts and
insecurities and as Joan Amos said if
you aren't going all the way why go at
all rule number 29 be willing to pay the
price whatever your skill set is now
whatever your vision of yourself is now
you can change it you can become
anything you want to be but life is
gonna ask you one simple question what
price are you willing to pay to get
there and that's it that's the hard
truth if you're willing to pay the price
and you can become whatever you want you
can become truly capable of the
extraordinary but you've got to go
through the process of building that
skillset you've got to be willing to
stare naked Liat your inadequacies to
understand that you aren't yet the
person that you want to be or need to be
to execute against your goals but that
you can become that person and then
start walking down that path and day by
day brick by brick build the skill set
that you want rule number 30 get started
as Haroon 'yeah noted i always wonder
why birds stay in the same place when
they can fly anywhere on earth and then
i ask myself the same question as mark
twain put it the secret of getting ahead
is getting started and that's where
people get stuck you're literally like
the bird you could fly anywhere you want
you can go anywhere you want to go and
look I know you've got a litany of
excuses and all of them are
you've got a job you can't just leave
well you don't have a job and you don't
have the money your family is in one
place it's the only thing that you've
ever known you only speak one language
you've never traveled before you don't
have a passport you can't afford the gas
money there are a thousand real reasons
not to go but the truth is that none of
them matter the truth is if you want to
build something in your life that you
have to remember what Mark Twain said
you have to get started because at the
end of the day that is literally the
only thing that's holding you back
you're not moving and once you get the
simplicity of that once you understand
that you could act right now you could
say all the excuses you can stop making
them you can stop giving into them no
matter how valid they are no matter how
real they may seem you can finally
decide that you're going to get up a
movie you're going to create that
momentum that you're going
take a step that you're gonna make the
demand that you create momentum that you
get something done but you find an
answer or as Hannibal said that you're
going to find a way or make one if you
have to carve through rock do it because
humans before you
and that's the simple truth that is the
simple is the weak voice in your mind
holding you back and making you a less
version of yourself so I asked you why
doesn't the bird fly wherever it wants
to go because that's all it's known
because that's what's safe because
that's what's comfortable
well because it's a dumb an animal what
do you want to be if this isn't the life
you want to live do something about it
rule number 31 focus on the adventure as
Ralph Waldo Emerson said we're all
inventors each sailing out on a voyage
of discovery guided each by a private
chart of which there is no duplicate
we're all lost at sea we're all on this
grand adventure but the punchline is we
have no idea where we're going and the
map that we have is private only to us
and it's quite frankly blank and it's
about filling it in it's about learning
where you are it's about finding
guideposts and beginning to build this
map only from that which you've done and
so you have to go blindly forward and
the only thing that's going to give you
the courage to step into that abyss to
step into the truly unknown into the
dangerous world before you truly into a
sea of infinite peril the only thing
that's going to give you the courage to
do that is that you can learn that
you'll figure it out it's not going to
be easy it's going to be hard and at
times it is truly going to be
life-threatening but that
the nature of life and as you're out
there in the wilderness as you're out
there lost at sea all you have to do is
remember two things it is an adventure
and adventures are never safe but the
rewards of an adventure or the discovery
of something entirely new and two you
can do it you can do it the very fact
that you're a human gives you the
ability to process your surroundings to
figure things out to go in and fumble
around you're not going to look good
you're going to drink a ton of ocean
water and it is going to suck and you're
gonna be vomiting over the sides and it
is going to be difficult there are going
to be times when you're convinced you're
going to drown but if in those moments
you stay clear-headed and you focus on
getting better you focus on the
adventure you don't worry about the
outcome you just focus on right now in
this moment with everything going wrong
what can I learn to calm yourself and to
remember right there if you're panicking
you're asking the wrong question if
you're panicking you're asking questions
about how you look you're asking
questions about how this is going to end
up if you want to kill your panic in any
moment ask yourself right then and there
what can I learn what can I learn
through this life is nothing but
practice and as long as you keep that in
mind as long as you understand it's
never a performance it's always practice
it's simply an opportunity to learn and
get better then you can reframe the
entire ordeal that you're going through
and as Paulo Coelho said people are
capable at any time in their lives of
doing what they dream of but it's only
going to come true
through that process of learning and
discovery and putting yourself out there
and going into the unknown but if you're
never willing to step off because all
you can see are the problems all you can
see are the things that could go wrong
and you never get the chance to learn
but the way that you learn is truth
engagement is through interacting and if
you don't dare to do that if you don't
dare to step out into the unknown and to
flounder around and look stupid and
embarrass yourself then you're never
gonna grow and if you never grow then
you're never going to make your dreams
come true so if you have that dream
locked inside of you know that the only
way to get it out is to risk to dare to
strive to try
to grow to grow to fall to fail
to learn and ultimately succeed that's
the only way that dreams come true rule
number 32 surround yourself with success
so then these two successful
entrepreneurs walk into my class and up
to that point I promised myself two
things so I grew up chubby and a
morbidly obese family and with no money
and I said one day I'm gonna be rich and
one day I'm gonna have six-pack ABS hmm
and that was my promise and these guys
walked in and they were rich they had
six-pack ABS and they said look we're
starting a technology company why don't
you come be a copywriter and I was like
absolutely and it's one of those where
people like what are you doing like
you're leaving the secure job for me I
was like they're like unicorns to me
yeah they are literally the thing I'm
looking for yeah they are rich and they
have six-pack ABS they're gonna let me
into their company yeah and so their
whole pitch was look man this is a
startup you're gonna have any job in
this company you want you just have to
become the right person for the job
so it was a tech company it was in this
beautiful office overlooking the Pacific
Ocean every single person in that
company had a floor-to-ceiling window
overlooking the Pacific Ocean except me
and they put me in the server room which
had no windows and a bunch of computers
all whirring and making noise and
remember one of the guys was like who's
the kid in the server room and so that's
how I became known I was the kid in the
server room I know anything about
business I would bring my wife she's to
visit me in the office and I'm like look
how beautiful the offices and this is
where I mean I you know am I literally
like those makeshift desks that are like
really like a table that you would use
on a picnic you've got a computer
stacked on it that's where I worked all
day do you believe big time that
identity is shaped by these associations
in everybody's life 100% talk about that
for size so it's so aggressive and it's
now getting repeated so I fear trite
words but words become trite because
they're so true that people repeat them
until they lose their meaning
so you're the average of the five people
you spend the most time with that's just
true and but now it's become so common
to say and it's like every Instagram
post that you know I fear it's gonna
lose its meaning who are you spending
time with because if you're spending
time with people like you you're
spending time with people like me I'm
raising you up I'm just not gonna spend
time with you hmm so it's like now if
you get in a mix of people like that who
are like
man we'd love for you to raise up to
this level but if you don't it's fine
but we're just not gonna spend time with
you all of a sudden that desire to
belong to something powerful that you
can see is gonna lead you to your dreams
and I remember saying to my wife over
and over and over
they are the surest path to my success I
don't know anything else
I just know if I can hang on to these
guys they're gonna make me better
rule number 33 don't have a victims
mentality literally the first time I
wrote this whole article it was my first
blog article and it was all about how if
I were hit by a drunk driver I would
take ownership of that I would say that
is my fault and people were pissed and I
was so shocked I literally thought I
want to pull people from the matrix
what's the one gift that I could give
people that will change their life
forever and I wrote this whole thing and
I was like talking about like oh man
you're in this spot and it ends up being
a kill box and there's cars on either
side of you in a car in front of you and
your horn dies and you can't even start
your car and move you look in the
rearview mirror and this drunk drivers
plowing down they smashed into you and
it's all your fault and thank God
because now you remember that you're in
control but people thought I was victim
shaming people were outraged that I
would say that that was anyone's fault
but the drunk driver but I don't want to
do that because I choose not to ever be
a victim I cannot choose whether I'm
victimized but I have the ability to say
I will never be a victim because there's
always something you can do differently
there is always something you can do
differently and once you understand that
you can always make a different choice
and get a different reaction and that's
the power in your life that's the power
that you have is no matter what's going
on you can choose to think differently
believe differently see differently all
of those things are a choice Reid man's
search for meaning by Viktor Frankl lost
his whole family to the Holocaust was in
I think five different concentration
camps and he said the thing that people
die of in a constant
raishin camp is the loss of a why and
Nietzsche said if you have a why you can
survive almost any how because you can
always change how you think about
something and when you change how you
think about it's what we've been talking
about all day when you change how you
think about it you actually change the
event rule number 34 don't hold yourself
back here's the problem I find most
people have they judge themselves to the
lens of a moment they fail at something
they miss the honor club they don't
close that deal they thought they were
going to they embarrass themselves they
flub something and they think that
defines who they are but I'm telling you
right now you're not defined but who you
are you're defined by who you want to
become and the price you're willing to
pay to get there rule number 35 continue
to push here's the hard truth about
getting great it takes time and
dedication it takes a willingness to
accept that you're not yet good enough
it takes the ability to stare at the
places that you know that you're weak to
really look at those things and not let
it affect your sense of self-esteem and
not let it affect your sense of
self-worth so that you can still get the
momentum going but you have to
understand that in the beginning we're
all terrible and as Henri
cartier-bresson said your first 10,000
photographs are your worst and so the
thing that really makes great art are
the people that continue to push and the
people that continue to work and face
how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the
de greatness is a craft greatness is a
process greatness is a habit greatness
is the little things that you do every
day
overtime going out every day on the
fraid of whether or not this is one of
the 10,000 terrible things that you're
gonna do it's being unafraid to make
those mistakes as being unafraid that
you're not yet great and as Mary Ann rad
maker said courage doesn't always war
sometimes courage is the quiet voice at
the end of the day saying I will try
again tomorrow and that's it if you want
to be great that's what you have to do
you've got to get up again tomorrow
you've got to be willing to face another
day you've got to be willing to accept
that you've got to get through the bad
ideas before you can get to the good
you've got to understand that you have
to start as an apprentice you have to
start as a person going and getting tea
and you have to accept that that's the
job that you should be playing that you
should be working for somebody else you
should be looking up to somebody else's
seeing what they can teach you because
what you know is that you're there
you're there to get through the 10,000
bad photographs you need to get through
to ultimately achieve greatness and if
you make the catastrophic error that's
so many made to try to tell the water
you're extraordinary
to try to get the wool to fall
look up to you and Faithie or something
today
because the people that live in
the ones that listen today the ones that
spend every ounce of their energy
amassing mastery getting better every
day working their asses off to improve
their skill set to relentlessly look at
the things that they're not doing well
to understand that they have to break
themselves down and get rid of all of
their ego before they can really find
greatness those are the people that we
remember so if you want to be remembered
if you want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day and take another swing
take another photo
try another task do something that
scares you and do those little things
over and over and over until you win
rule number 36 don't be an empty dreamer
the one thing I will say is I was
grandly ambitious
I always said I'm gonna be rich I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that
always always since the time I was a
little kid but I didn't have the drive
to see it through so I really really was
an empty dreamer when I was a kid and it
was learning to hate that in myself if
I'm completely honest and to not allow
myself to be an empty dreamer to force
myself to get the skills to actually
execute against it to not be in any way
shape or form pacified by saying I'm
gonna do something which is actually
super dangerous
most people just thinking about the
fantasy of what they're gonna do gives
them some partial sense of oh I've done
it mmm whereas I stopped letting that be
okay for me which largely came down to
embarrassment I felt around my wife
working when I had no job and that was
the time she was my fiancee at the time
yeah but that was when I really started
to go okay you've made a lot of promises
to this woman and you're not on a path
to keep any of them rule number 37 take
responsibility tom am I going to make it
do I have what it takes when you look
into my future can you see me making it
and I'm gonna cut to the chase for all
of you and your mistake what I'm about
to say for good news and then I'm gonna
tell you why it's actually the worst
thing I could tell you you all meet
minimum requirements you all meet
minimum requirements so whatever it is
you want to do I'm not gonna say that
it's gonna be easy for you because
you're ultra smart or something you
probably aren't but everyone that I've
encountered here literally without
exception every single person that has
come up to me and said something you
meet minimum requirements even you
awkward that have a hard time like
making eye contact even you guys I'm
telling you
right now you've got something you're
gonna have to deal with but you meet
minimum requirements
now minimum requirements for what for
whatever you want
now that sounds great right oh [ __ ]
Tom said I can make it this is amazing
but all I've actually said is now if you
don't make it it's on you and that's it
there's nobody else to blame
everything is your fault
everything rule number 38 change your
mindset once you understand the whole
reason to acquire a skill is that it
gives you power
now I'm gonna define power power to me
is the ability to close your eyes and
imagine a world the world the way you
wish it was and then open your eyes and
make that world come true that's power
and the thing that stands between you
where you are today and your goals where
you want to get is a gap in skill set it
is a gap in abilities and once you're
willing to look naked Liat your
inadequacies to literally build your
self-esteem your entire sense of
self-worth and value is built around one
thing whenever you face an obstacle
whenever you face a difficulty whenever
you fail you have one thing that you say
to yourself on a long enough timeline I
can learn this when you switch your life
around to that whatever your goal is
here whatever part of the honors Club or
the leading edge you're at or if you
want to go beyond that
whatever that is wherever you want to go
plant that flag identify the skills that
you would need to get there and then set
about everyday getting those skills rule
number 39 empower yourself people get
the do part they understand their action
should be actions that take them towards
what they want to accomplish
but people often miss the most important
part which is only to believe things
that move you towards your goals and I
see people every day that tell
themselves the story about themselves
that they are worthless that they're
meaningless that they're pointless that
their friends and family would be better
off if they just died so we have to find
a way to construct a narrative about
ourselves that empowers us that lifts us
up even though even though we make
mistakes even though we fall down even
though we're never going to get things
right all the time and even though
terrible things happen to us or maybe we
do terrible things but in that the
erosion of the self that's the danger
the erosion of the self that is the
danger and when I talk to people about
the 80/20 principle 80 percent of the
time you should be focused on the things
that you love the beautiful things that
you want to bring to this world the
beautiful things that are already in the
world and 20% of the time you should be
kicking yourself in your ass and saying
you can do better it's such a powerful
idea but the problem is when people get
to the 20% they forget that it's only
supposed to be 20% of the time and that
it's meant to be these acute moments
where you're pushing yourself to be more
to do more it isn't so you can tear
yourself down that's why you have to do
and believe that which moves you towards
your goals and if thinking that you're a
worthless piece of [ __ ] moves you to
your goals somehow then fine do it but I
can't literally fathom a universe in
which that would be a logical way to
move forward so I'm going to give you
the magic words that you need right now
to never fall prey to that believing I'm
worthless does not serve me and I don't
do things that don't serve me repeat
that in your head
every time you begin to disparage
yourself rule number 40 wanted badly
enough here's the harsh reality you're
just not good enough yet as brian tracy
said your true success in life begins
only when you make the commitment to
become excellent at what you do this is
the gap that I see in most people's
lives did not yet made the commitment to
become extraordinary and the reason that
they haven't made that commitment yet is
they don't believe that they can they're
afraid of what it might take to get
there
they just don't want it enough that's
the reality most people don't want it
enough to face all of that they don't
want to face their inadequacies they
don't want to accept that they're gonna
have to go through that process that gut
wrenching back-breaking process of
becoming great and every day lulls them
into this sense that there's always time
to do it tomorrow but the reality is
there is only now there is only today
and if you really want to do something
with your life that leaves your own jaw
on the floor that leaves you in awe of
what you've done you're going to have to
admit you're not yet good enough you've
got to put in that work that you've got
to develop a set of skills that simply
can't be denied but if you do that on
the other side of getting that good and
falling in love with something and
working so hard that you can feel
yourself changing as a human being on
the other side of that is something
unimaginably beautiful and as Les Brown
said if you set goals and go after them
with all the determination you can
muster your gifts will take you places
that will amaze you
that's what I want in my life and I hope
that's what you want in yours is to be
amazed to be amazed at how extraordinary
this life really is this opportunity to
make of yourself anything you want to be
really think about that for a second you
can become anything you want to become
you could become an astronaut a
world-class athlete a musician the best
parent that this world has ever seen
anything you want is yours for the
taking
but it takes effort it takes a
willingness to stare naked Liat your
inadequacies it takes a willingness to
really gut check yourself about where
you are today and it doesn't mean that
you can't go and be something better
tomorrow and falling in love with that
process that knowing - being a human and
really getting the most out of your
potential is that to know that tomorrow
I can be better than I am today and that
doesn't make you a bad person
today it's okay to know that you can be
better tomorrow and still love yourself
today but it's also okay to love
yourself today and demand that you get
better tomorrow and once you can do that
there is literally nowhere you can't go
rule number 41 take the pain so I would
get kicked in the face and I would do
something really dumb I'd be called an
idiot told how stupid I was and then I'd
just be like all right I need to
recenter and that just became my
obsession I need to be able to
emotionally get back to complete neutral
so fast that you don't even see a
register on my face to do it how do you
do that literally practicing so I could
get I could be in a situation where I'm
being berated or or illegitimate ly mess
up and it costs money and it's like whoa
that's on me and it does nobodies Bab of
my own and I realized that what most
people do their strategy is to deflect
it it's your faults not my fault yes so
I started thinking of this as a metaphor
people are throwing gold at me they're
throwing it really hard and I can put a
shield up and deflect it but then I lose
that piece of gold and if I drop my
shield and just take the pain let it hit
me in the head then I bend down and go
this thing which was me being stupid
there's a lesson here come and now I
have this piece of gold but
the whole thing is I have to be
defenseless so I have to own it I have
to take it I can't fight if someone is
like this to this day if our team is
like hey there's something we need to
point out to you I'll do this I square
up to it I want them to know like hey I
want to hear it I want to know like I
want to be literally physically open I'm
not going to close down I'm gonna do
everything I can to square off to open
myself so that they know I'm receptive
to the criticism right because that's
the nugget of gold what I know is it's
gonna hurt it's gonna sting yeah but if
I can emotionally recenter so fast you
don't even see that I went through
something now I can just process how do
I take this information you've given me
and get better rule number 42 find
fulfillment I went through the pain of
living the cliche of money can't buy
happiness early so that was the very
thing that gave birth to my true
financial success walking through that
though so as most people will never
experience what it's like to come into
crazy wealth yeah it is it is a really
funny moment and funny is the right word
it's it's fun but it's also funny in
that when I was growing up part of the
reason I wanted to get rich was I looked
at those people with admiration and I
did not look at myself with admiration
so I thought oh well if I can get
wealthy then I will look at myself with
admiration this would be amazing and
then when I got the money by then I had
changed myself fundamentally as a person
that I had earned so much self-respect
and so much self-worth that by the time
I got the money I didn't I wasn't
looking for anything from the money
other than it is dog great facilitator
it will let you do extraordinary things
but it won't make you an extraordinary
person and won't make you feel any
differently about yourself and because
the money came literally like that
because we had paper wealth so I was a
worth hundreds of millions of dollars on
paper but I just cannot stress enough
that's meaningless in your real life I
was driving you know at one point a
beat-up Ford Focus my wife and I had to
share it had a leaky exhaust and yet I'm
worth at that point I was worth tens of
millions of dollars but there were
employees that were living far better
lives and I was from a financial
standpoint
so that's paper money now bank account
money came in an instant and so it was
about I don't know six years into our
journey and we decided to take a small
investment to diversify so it was a pure
foul
liquidity moment and because the
valuation the company was over a billion
dollars you can imagine even at a small
percentage just the rod number of
dollars is in sanity so all the sudden I
was fantastically wealthy but I was like
it is so in fact this this was how that
day went so everyone I said earlier you
beliefs values identity habits routines
right these are the things that make
people up and I just have a value system
that says it's not about the money it's
about building something you believe and
it's about serving other people it's
about work ethic it's about showing up
and working and I value myself for that
so on the day that the money hit it hit
it like I know 8:00 a.m. in the morning
or something and my wife were both in
the gym and she's like what are we gonna
do today
knows like what do you mean I'm going to
work and she like couldn't wrap her head
around aha she's like oh we are gonna go
to the Lamborghini dealer yeah she's
like come on we've got to like go do
something we got to celebrate and I'm
like there's no universe in which I
don't show up for work today
none under no circumstances so if you
were to ask my employees when did the
money hit the hell would be like I have
no idea they knew that it did hit but
they didn't know what day because I
acted completely the same and the things
I want people to understand is I feel
the same so all of the like things that
I believe about myself to be good
I still believe to be good I earned them
I earned them by doing the hard thing
time and time and time and time again I
know how much I'm willing to serve
people and my family and myself and all
I just know I've done it for years and
years and years so when it came to do I
buy an island and retire or do I double
down it came down to what will make me
love my life the most and the reality is
the thing that would make me love my
life the most because it would still be
fun to just go home be with my wife but
the thing that make me love my life the
most is to do the things that are
fulfilling and I think fulfillment has a
very specific universal formula and that
formula is work your ass off to get very
good at something that you care deeply
about that allows you to serve not only
yourself but other people that's it you
got to have all of it rule number 43
use your potential as Buckminster Fuller
said there's nothing in a caterpillar
that tells you that it's going to be a
butterfly and welcome to the human
condition that's the truth of what it's
like to be a person you're hoping that
you turn inward and see some sign some
glimmer some gift that you have that's
been bestowed upon you that you were
born with that is your very birthright
but there's nothing you were born
hopelessly average and the sooner that
you accept that the sooner that you
accept that you were no better than
anyone that came before you and everyone
that's going to come after you but all
of us have potential and so the question
becomes the question you have to answer
with your very life the question that
your actions will answer what are you
gonna do with that potential will you
actuate it will you bust your ass to get
good will you get so good over time that
you can play with the greats will you
get so good that people look at you with
awe can you get so good that you become
the excuse that other people use not to
try can you get so good that people have
to dismiss you as naturally talented can
you get so good the people refuse to
believe that they
good can you work so hard gaining a set
of skills and driving yourself day after
day to get better never accepting who
you are always pushing yourself bored
always demanding more and seeing the
beauty in what you can become and
knowing that even today as a caterpillar
with nothing with nothing to indicate
you become a butterfly can you become
the butterfly do sheer force of will
because if you can become that you
become a beacon of hope not for other
people for yourself because you prove
that there really are no limits and as
Walt Disney said you may not realize it
when it happens but a kicking of teeth
may be the best thing in the world for
you why because it's the thing that's
going to make you react it's the thing
that's gonna hold you down it's the
thing that is going to make you say
never again no more I refuse to accept
this about myself I refuse to accept
that I'm average I refuse to accept that
I can't be something more I refuse to
stop when something kicks me in the
teeth I refuse to stop when people hate
on me or tell me that I can't do
something I refuse to be dictated to by
anyone even my own potential I refuse to
be held back by anything least of all me
rule number 44 find your why and for me
it was I grew up in a morbidly obese
family my uncle essentially ate himself
to death when I was 12 years old and it
was scary and sad my mom is morbidly
obese has been my entire life my
sister's morbidly obese has been almost
her entire life my dad at one point was
morbidly obese and then lost weight but
it was like that's just where my family
lived yeah and so I was like they're
going to die far sooner than they need
to and there's this great mother Theresa
quote nobody will act for the many but
people will act for the one and then so
I just needed to wake up every day and
think about my mom and my sister and
that was it and I thought I can show up
every day and fight for them it's not
about the money anymore I can fight for
them rule number 45 achieved mastery
Cheers this may be the biggest problem
we face as a society people don't
remember that skills have utility they
let you do something you don't learn to
build a house to impress your parents
you learn to build a house so people can
live in the house you build and
once people understand that like holy Sh
you're building this house so somebody
can live in it build a home in it have a
family be sheltered from storms like
it's a real thing man and so all of that
effort and energy went into I have the
chills right now is so you can create
that moment for yourself for other
people it is it is something so much
more than going to architecture school
which maybe you win too because your
parents wanted that and they they were
architects and so you do that thing for
that and you forget the whole reason you
became an architect was to build houses
and so once people realize oh I'm
putting all of this time and energy to
build these things because they let me
do something what do I want to do what
do I want to give what do I want to
create when you look at skills from that
perspective it is like it is being a
superhero it is being a superhero you're
going to collect these abilities these
abilities actually let you do something
the fact that Superman can fly allows
him to save people allows him to do
things other people can't do we all have
this opportunity to become capable of
the extraordinary to be able to do
things other people can't do and that
feels so good
rule number 46 take ownership I'm gonna
tell you a story and this story pisses
people off and it goes like this my wife
who happens to be British big it up for
England let's say that she is with her
mom and she's in the bedroom that she
grew up in she's all safe and sound the
doors locked the alarm is on her mom's
in the next room making sure that she's
safe but right then a meteorite comes
screaming through the atmosphere crashes
into her bedroom and kills her whose
fault is that I know some of listen to
my content
I will tell you that right now now if
people don't know me everybody goes to
it's dumb luck divine providence it's
nobody's fault
how could you blame yourself well let me
tell you how I could blame myself and
when you hear the reality of this and
you realize that I am in no way shape or
form being hyperbolic it actually is my
fault
here's why I know right now
there is an organization that track what
are called near-earth objects in fact
I'm on the board of the XPrize one of
the prizes that they're trying to raise
money for is for this problem to track
all these known objects and to find some
way lasers planted nuclear explosions
something to make sure that if something
is ever on a collision course for Earth
that we can stop it literally four
weekends ago I had a chance to vote for
this to say this should be a prize and I
didn't so now not only have I never sent
a dime of my money to help I've never
sent an email with encouraging words
I've never called them up
to tell them what I think they should do
now I literally voted against them so if
a meteorite happens to kill my wife I
don't have anyone to believe in myself
that's so apparently true now I think
it's the right decision I think they're
putting the time and energy into
something that has such a vanishingly
slim possibility of actually happening
makes no sense
you have to know where to put your
energies all of us have a finite amount
of energy so you at some point have to
triage and decide what are the things
that I'm going to attack I'm far more
worried about my wife getting into a car
the likelihood of her dying is almost
certainly going to be at this point
something to do with heart disease or
something to do with an aneurism things
like that
it most certainly isn't going to be a
meteorite crashing through the roof and
killing her but if it did I wouldn't
waste time blaming anyone else now the
key here the key I wouldn't beat myself
up over it I would be crestfallen my
wife is my everything it would be a loss
so devastating I don't even want to
comprehend it but I just wouldn't waste
time blaming anyone else because the
reality is and let this come home your
life is the exact reflection of the
choices you have made love your life
great you've made awesome choices hate
your life I'm sorry you've made bad
choices but the good news is you're in
control
rule number 47 have clarity take us a
little bit through quest for a few
minutes what made it work like what did
you do that was crazy that other people
didn't do our mantra was you can tell
the world to eat less and exercise more
and it will work for every single person
ever that's ever done it but the reality
is the vast majority of the world will
not do that and we already know that
right so people wouldn't saying that for
like 60 70 years so we're moving in the
wrong direction so our thing was don't
change behavior leverage it so we
already know people will eat things they
want to eat you can't stop people from
eating a chocolate chip cookie so the
question was could you make a chocolate
chip cookie that was actually good for
them so that metabolically was actually
advantageous to eat that cookie could we
bust our asses that hard to make that
thing and so it wasn't easy but now we
had a mission we wanted to end metabolic
disease now when you have that clarity I
know people are going to eat things
based on taste purely so we know we have
to address that which is why we made
snack foods instead of like you know
coming out with broccoli and
you know we just seemed exactly good we
made chips and so but if you called
quest's and said hey I want to get in
shape what should I eat our answer was
boiled chicken breasts and steamed
broccoli because that's the truth yes
right so we're not trying to pull a fast
one we want people to know they can
trust us we know where our products fit
in you when you absolutely have to have
a chocolate chip cookie eat our
chocolate chip cookie rule number 48 be
patient you jumped into this startup
situation because I'm not getting from
you that business was a driving force
for you as a kid it was about art and
expression yes 1000% I am NOT a born
entrepreneur yeah not in the slightest
and I part of the reason that my
philosophies are what they are is
because I have lived them so when I talk
about the you know having a negative
voice it's because I have one and it is
aggressive I want to talk about
anxieties because I had anxiety when I
talk about being able to become an
entrepreneur it's because I had to so I
didn't have the instincts in fact from
an instinct perspective I didn't have
any and I had to learn all of that now I
would say I do have good business
instincts because I've trained them over
time but I certainly didn't have them in
the beginning and in the beginning of my
business career the and this is real and
I really want people to feel what I feel
when I say this the only contributions
that I would make for probably the first
two years of being in business the only
contributions I would make to a
conference call were to say goodbye and
I remember looking forward to that I was
finally gonna get to say something but
because at least I knew enough to keep
my mouth shut when I didn't know and I
didn't understand I didn't want to look
stupid so I would just be quiet I would
listen and learn I'm very grateful to
the guys that gave me that opportunity
they would let me on the call so I was
often in rooms that I probably would
never have been allowed to be in if I'd
been in a traditional company but
because it was a startup
they just kept letting me listen in on
phone calls and stuff so that ended up
being really really extraordinary for me
but yeah I had to learn to be an
entrepreneur
rule number 49 get better every day
here's the hard truth about getting
great
it takes time and dedication it takes a
willingness to accept that you're not
yet good enough it takes the ability to
stare at the places that you know that
you're weak to really look at those
things and not let it affect your sense
of self-esteem and not let it affect
your sense of self-worth so that you can
still get the momentum going but you
have to understand that in the beginning
we're all terrible and as Henri
cartier-bresson said your first 10,000
photographs are your worst and so the
thing that really makes great art are
the people that continue to push and the
people that continue to work and face
how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process greatness is a habit greatness
is the little things that you do every
day
overtime going out every day unafraid of
whether or not this is one of the 10,000
terrible things that you're gonna do
it's being unafraid to make those
mistakes as being unafraid that you're
not yet great and as Marianne rad maker
said courage doesn't always war
sometimes courage is the quiet voice at
the end of the day saying I will try
again tomorrow and that's it
if you want to be great that's what you
have to do you've got to get up again
tomorrow you've got to be willing to
face another day you've got to be
willing to accept that you've got to get
through the bad ideas before you can get
to the good you've got to understand
that you have to start as an apprentice
you have to start as a person going and
getting tea and you have to
but that's the job that you should be
playing that you should be working for
somebody else you should be looking up
to somebody else's seeing what they can
teach you because what you know is that
you're there to learn what you know this
they're to get through the 10,000 bad
photographs that you need to get through
to ultimately to achieve greatness and
if you make the catastrophic error
that's so many make to try to tell the
world do extraordinary today to try to
get the world to follow you and look up
through and think a or something today
because the people that living in
the ones that listen today the ones that
spend every ounce of their energy
amassing mastery getting better every
day working their asses off to improve
their skill set to relentlessly look at
the things that they're not doing well
to understand that they have to break
themselves down and get rid of all of
their ego before they can really find
greatness those are the people that we
remember so if you want to be remembered
if you want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day and take another swing
take another photo try another task do
something that scares you and do those
little things over and over and over
until you win and rule number 50 the
last one in for a very special bonus
clip has become unstoppable as over
Winfrey said what you dwell on is what
you become
once you understand that humans are the
ultimate adaptation machine and you
understand that the brain actually
builds faster and better connections
between the things that you think on you
will begin to understand that it is
incredibly important to be thoughtful
about what you think about it's
incredibly important to pick a direction
that you want to grow in to decide who
you want to become and then make that at
the center of your focus your thoughts
your time your energy and if you look
inward or if you look outward and you
don't like what you see remember what
Jim Rohn said if you don't like how
things are change it you're not a tree
and that's the beauty that's the
beautiful thing about being a human we
are so plastic and we can change so
dramatically we are so good at adapting
that we forget that's literally what we
do
but if you can take control of that
process if you can grab ahold of it and
make it your own if you can make it your
daily obsession to make the most of your
potential to pick a very specific
direction to pick an end goal and end
state and end identity and work your way
backwards find out the steps that you're
going to need to take to get there to
execute and have the willingness to put
in the work to have the willingness to
be both the sculptor and the clay to
understand that the suffering that comes
with that of changing yourself of making
yourself into something great is the
suffering well worth it it's a suffering
that you should embrace it's a suffering
that you should run towards because in
that suffering you can become anything
you want so start to dwell on
well on a vision of you being great
dwell on a vision of you accomplishing
your goals dwell on a vision of you
having done this amazing thing that you
want to do dwell on an image of you
being willing to sweat and bend yourself
in half and break if you need to and
bleed when necessary to become the
vision of yourself you always knew you
could become dwell on that and nothing
can sell
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Tom on how to focus on the light that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one how can you better
surround yourself with success number
two where are you holding yourself back
that you're going to stop today
and number three what is your strong why
find a place inside where there's joy
and the joy will burn out the pain now I
get it life inevitably comes with some
degree of misery and I get it
for many of you things have happened in
your past that are unspeakable and
whether that's something big or whether
it's something small each one of us has
something inside of us that hurts it's
something that we wish weren't so it's
something that we focus on when we're
alone it's the thing that keeps us up at
night it's the thing that wakes us up in
the morning it's the thing that we
obsessively come back to over and over
and over for whatever reason that we
think means that we're not good enough
but I also know that inside each one of
us is something beautiful that even in
the midst of pain if you allow yourself
to focus on that to feel the joy to not
just think about it but to actually feel
the joy it will begin to crowd out the
pain it will actually take that room and
just like when you're trying to create
something amazing in your life do not
waste time
trying to tear down the old if you're
trying to create something beautiful in
your life spend all of your time trying
to build that new thing so if you want
to feel joy
don't try to eradicate the pain instead
focus all of your energy on that joy and
let it become so bright that it
ultimately takes over the pain and as
aristotle said it is during our darkest
moments that we must focus to see light
and that's the thing with pleasure and
pain when you've got that ache inside of
you when you feel that something in your
past is stopping you from moving forward
it is in that moment that you must put
your focus and attention on the things
that are good on the things you've done
that are good on the joys and the beauty
and the things in your life do you're
grateful for all of that if you take
your time and you put your focus on that
even when it hurts especially when it
hurts if you're able to do that if
you're able to find a way to take all of
your energy and put it on that to repeat
it to let it become a mantra to let it
be the first thing you think about when
you wake up the last thing you think
about in the night and the thing that
you cling to when you wake up and cannot
fall asleep if you let it be that thing
that you can put all of your attention
on that then you can actually change
your chemistry you can actually change
your own story you can actually change
your life but you've got to know it's in
our darkest moments that we must focus
on the light if you want more time bill
you check that the top 50 rules your
video made on him as well the link is
right there next to me I'll see you
there
the only credit I will give myself is
when other people break and give up and
stop I just don't the thing that gives
you the most energy in life